un autre groupe a raison car tenant
france sniper pour ceux qui connaissent
pas sniper perso je les appelle les
snipers de la conjugaison embusqués si
nous avons en prime deux verbes adressés
ou à se mettre là à vous les
reconnaîtrez dans la rue se trimballe
avec des sacs carrefour de bécherel ils
vont bosser pour écouter un extrait de
sniper écouter mais ces dames la
conjugaison sait s'imposer
eh bien oui c'est tout s'arrange pas ce
serait mentir si je dirais que c'est
pareil
il faut casser morgan faible à quoi elle
a bon non pas vraiment mon jeune ami sam
en terre si je dirais que c'est pareil
si je disais m'emporte concordance des
temps ce2 avec les choses ce truc là les
mecs m'ont écrit il l'écrit se sont
montrés entre rappeurs 1 ça c'est de la
balle qui a cartonné est inquiète
connais tu as vu mais chantal goldstein
pression alors studio d'enregistrement
les mecs dans le studio d'enregistrement
il y avait l'ingé son chef de produit
chef de projet directeur marketing
manager le producteur tous les potes ils
ont écouté son 10e saison va cartonner
aux méfie-toi de ses amis là